how can something as beautiful as this
be dying a plague is ruining the land
but the Tree of Life still stands
question is for how long end is coming
to the New World
the tribes stand divided in need of
someone strong enough to unite them all
bring them all down this is a story with
an unusual beginning so let's expect
welcome to bio mutant you lose your
gender
yo dad I built Jody Jojo met Bob Jojo
met Bob yeah your old your DNA
[Music]
pick your fur type
[Music]
choose your first style
[Music]
pick your main color choose your detail
color that will work
[Music]
[Applause]
we're already at a crossroads choosing a
path in life is that fork in the road we
can make a choice or simply stop living
is not daughter right is always right
[Music]
and here it is the first turn of events
let's find out if your business
the predator is too strong who'd better
run for it
[Music]
character files you just spill the
deadly seeps from the tree of life those
who fight
chop-chop
[Music]
wonder what's in here
[Music]
jerk
[Music]
you found something
tada
[Music]
let's see what we can find
[Music]
wonder what's in here that stuff might
come in handy the big one wants to soak
in and smoke
speak everything don't you
that one had it come down a face
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
relax
switch it off the mouse nvb Popo
[Music]
[Music]
well ha
[Music]
[Music]
that there's something interesting
behind that door it's a workshop let's
see let's see what we can find good and
you found something
I'm the tide outdoors
Filipa Gear Solid
[Music]
looks good to me
[Music]
look a crowbar let's see if we can find
something else here that pipe looks weak
whoa it's time to find a way out of this
place no really I mean it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when a story comes to you it's important
I'm a little wonder what's in here
that stuff might come in handy
Gordo found something
empty will monitor nothing just hurry
that stuff might come in handy
[Music]
[Music]
the old one is outnumbered you better
help him
we're going into it cutting edge
rokda
what an end to it
that's the last of which cool
[Music]
LeBeau Jojo you ma seemed a good day he
wants to thank you for taking his side
against the tribe he sounds familiar you
just can't figure out why there are lots
of questions in need of answers seeing a
man or pig blood says you can call him
out of date
he knows he's way overdue but he hasn't
given up a name is a great way to start
a relation sarkozy out of dates reply as
quick perhaps you share the same
bloodline a name is a great way to start
a relation brian says he lost it to the
try added Megan at she bit it straight
off a name is a great way to start a
relation out-of-date nods want stuff car
seeing a man or pig blood there are lots
of questions in need of answers well
black dark a lot love its rossi green
he's nurtured since before the
apocalypse thing a mallard but he says
he has something special he wants to
show then he eyes your blade asks you to
cut the glitter grass he says no nose
can regenerate plant tissue he tells you
to guide the nonno to the pins i plant
let's not go to Holly Pandu Kojima Largo
it looks like he's right backups the
windows we'll be able to heal the tree
of life and he hopes you understand that
you will all die if the tree isn't
healed out of dates convinced your paths
crossed for a reason so far you've
proved you care about others and the
fate that awaits us all regardless he
expects you will play your part you
[Music]
oh he forgot one thing the contraption
he rigged to deadbolt the door triggered
after you came in you need to take care
of that first perhaps you should give
the crowbar another try
quickest way out is through the roof
where they came in the Rope looks strong
enough to climb let it be known that end
is coming to the new world
it's tribes stand divided in need of
someone brave enough to claim the throne
unite them or bring them all down
[Music]
Teegarden um but i double dude
[Music]